i have to make this one statement that
the person must really want the goal and
believe one the product will get you the
goal the way they want to get there and
i learned that second half the hard way
because we found out in gym launch that
people would say no sometimes to buying
memberships but when we offered them the
ability to come back the next day help
them for free we'd sell them 400 of
supplements and they just said no to 100
down service thing i'm like what the
[ __ ] it's because they want to lose
weight but they want to lose weight
their way and so that's when i started
learning like oh not only do we have to
make sure that they want the goal and
they believe that the product's going to
get them there it has to get them there
the way they want to get there the
second thing is that you and others will
support them like are you telling me the
truth is this really what's going to
happen will other people around me
support this decision and the third is
that it will work for them and not just
everyone else sure i've seen the people
who step on the stage but they're
different than me